bonjour alexis bonjour heureux de vous
retrouver ce matin sur rtl france alors
drôle de début de campagne pour anne
hidalgo qui peine à convaincre jusque
dans ses troupes oui vous avez montré
deux salles deux ambiances on a vu ce
début de campagne avec une timide roses
brandies par anne hidalgo pour
simplement lancé sa campagne avec
l'investiture du parti socialiste
72 % du vote un des socialistes c'est
pas énorme vu qu'elle est quasiment la
seule candidate elle est déjà contestée
en interne le discours d'olivier fort
assez catastrophique qui disaient tous
veulent nous voir perdre tous certains y
compris au parti socialiste aimerait
voir anne hidalgo perdre pour refonder
une gauche sociale démocrate s'est
compliqué pour elle on a l'impression
qu'elle n'a pas vraiment envie d'y aller
le discours qui a été lu du bout des
lèvres sur un papier la fiche de
campagne qui a été présentée alors sur
fond blanc avec un semi sourire une
police lambda avec ce slogan la courage
la justice rien vraiment qui ressort de
cette affiche de campagne l'impression
qu'elle ne veut pas y aller que c'est
particulier et il ya un fond blanc cassé
puis voilà c'est à peu près tout ce qui
ressort de ce début de campagne et anne
hidalgo qui continuent de plafonner dans
les sondages à 6% 7% c'est très peu
compte tenu de ce qui a été le parti
socialiste est bien sûr un manque de
programmes criant alors il ya eu
quelques annonces 1 le doublement du
salaire des professeurs le stop les
taxes sur les carburants mais personne
ne comprend réellement la logique ni
quel est le fil directeur de ce
programme qu'elle est en train de
construire donc on va attendre dans les
semaines qui viennent de voir si cette
campagne prend ou si c'est finalement
une campagne qui prépare les
législatives plutôt que les
présidentielles alors avec 6 à l'opposé
il ya jean luc mélenchon qui a lui de
nouveau réuni ses troupes à reims pour
une mise à jour du programme oui alors
jean-luc mélenchon c'est le candidat
perpétuel un troisième campagne pour le
candidat soumis qui a propres peuvent
profiter du du stop à reims pour goûter
quelques champagne et pour mobiliser ses
troupes 2001 soumis qui étaient là parce
que jean luc mélenchon même si c'est sa
troisième campagne compte bien être au
deuxième tour il l'a dit nous pouvons
être au 2e tour à ses adhérents et il
compte sur la mobilisation de tous ses
adhérents pour aller justement faire du
porte à porte et récupérer les un
million de jeunes qui manqueraient ce
parce qu'ils ne sont pas inscrits sur
les listes de vote donc à la fois le
vote des jeunes à la fois le vote des
abstentionnistes est un pari énorme que
tente jean luc mélenchon d'aller faire
voter ceux qui ne votent pas et ils
demandent également bien sûr une levée
de fonds de la part de ses militants 2,5
millions d'euros qui sont l'objectif à
d'ici à la fin de l'année mais on voyait
une énergie et l' envie d'être au
deuxième tour même si beaucoup disent
que cette croisée de cette troisième
campagne est peut-être celle de trop
pour le leader a soumis qui certes
connaît bien les mécaniques mais paraît
usé pour certains et bien sûr a réussi à
organiser quand même autour de lui une
nouvelle génération
d'insoumis et qui cherche l'union
populaire le plus difficile maintenant
pour jean luc mélenchon évidemment c'est
l'union peut-il faire une union à gauche
il y à quelques figures de gauche 1
de guyane et d'ailleurs qui rallie jean
luc mélenchon mathy le panneau est
maintenant responsable du pôle 1 soumis
à l'assemblée nationale qu'en sera-t-il
de la suite réussira-t-il ce pari à
faire voter les abstentionnistes tout
reste à tout reste à faire alors
certains rêvent encore d'union à gauche
c'est possible ou est-ce que c'est
définitivement impossible assez
compliqué à l'union à gauche hein je
crois qu'ils sont de moins en moins
nombreux à en parler regardez ne
serait-ce que chez europe ecologie les
verts yannick jadot qui annonce ce
week-end qu'il n'avait finalement aucun
gage a donné à sandrine rousseau donc il
fera ce qu'il veut depuis qu'il à
l'investiture alors évidemment déjà rien
que pour les électeurs de sandrine
rousseau la primaire des écologistes
il commence à regarder du côté de la
france insoumise et puis vous avez
évidemment arnaud montebourg qui cherche
aussi où aller parce que sa campagne est
légalement ne décolle pas malgré le
titre la remonte à da lui est en train
de dire même que les 32 heures 7 hors de
question c'est impossible c'est le
pouvoir d'achat qui compte on est très
loin la de messages de candidats de
gauche et puis pour ce qui est d'une
union mène entre le parti socialiste et
le élevé beaucoup à gauche commence à
regarder du côté de yannick jadot et a
abandonné le parti socialiste c'est le
cas de monsieur lamy ancien ministre de
françois hollande qui décide lui d'aller
vers yannick jadot directement par
conviction personnelle et non pas pour
chercher des places aux législatives
comme ça a été dit donc on voit bien que
la politique politicienne celle des
places des sièges celle du calcul elle a
vécu pour cette campagne et que ça va
être une campagne sans doute de
conviction donc pour l'union de la
gauche c'est extrêmement difficile de
mettre ensemble des gens qui n'ont pas
grand chose en commun on voit le même
problème à droite avec l ère qui
commence à se poser beaucoup de
questions sur son avenir donc cette
campagne présidentielle va finalement
être une campagne aussi de
redistribution des cartes et de
reformations du paysage politique en
france merci alexis à l'édito politique
d'alexis poulin a retrouvé tous les
lundis matin dans la matinale de rtl
france également sur les réseaux sociaux
fois